I was called names such as monster to
face and Scarface hey guys welcome back
to my channel posting my videos made me
realize that this is my mission I
wouldn't take it back this is absolutely
the reason why it happened to me
hey guys welcome back to my channel if
you're new my name is Sheila black today
we are going to be doing makeup my name
is Shalom and I make youtube videos I
teach people how to do makeup and also
encourage them to love himself
Budhia without the makeup I was burned
by a cooking oil when I was 9 years old
and my mother's restaurant back in
Nigeria I remember waking up to
screaming and pulling off my skin and
rubbing out my face
it was really terrible for me
I thought of suicide I was in the mural
just looking at myself like why don't
people just like me
I know that my mom loved me and she
would be really on sad to lose the child
you know because she felt like she lost
one
this is where pretty I started to feel
better about myself when I saw other
people that were burnt too and I wanted
to help people like me
my solution was trying to cover up my
scar so I thought why not
oh makeup this is going to be talked
through step by step how I cover up the
scar in my face when I get comments for
my viewers telling me that I help them
it makes me remember why I'm doing this
I like to focus positivity on my videos
you know not just putting on the makeup
but having a message that comes with it
that makeup isn't just what I love to do
you know I want to make you feel good
even when you don't have the makeup on
I'm just happy because I found myself I
learned to accept my scars and I also
just love me for who I am
you